alors ce poisson il a eu droit ni au
fond finit bien pas exactement
le vieil homme tombe sur un adversaire
redoutable alors qu'il pensait que ça
lui arriverait plus pourquoi il l'a pas
relâchés dans ce cas le vieil homme ça
vieil homme et le poisson c'est le
poisson pansements aux deux fois de soi
même
quoi qu'il arrive et un papy jeu paraît
que tu pouvais pas les chariots dans ton
nom c'est un boulot puis les masquer tu
pourras me recrédité une cartographie
ouf c'est de caisse et pas
d'histoire même toit
finement à la bague aussi
c'est quoi la nouvelle de l'histoire
d'un gars qui se prend pour un chevalier
en armure sauf qu'il vit dans un monde
où les chevaliers n'existe plus attaque
je pense qu'on peut être ce qu'on peut
être change de monde
j'avais promis je ne reviendrai jamais
cet homme là mais quand quelqu'un se
comporte de façon inhumaine avec une
inconnue alors tu réagi parce que tu
peux le faire je viens pour la fille 16
secondes
ouais
19 secondes
tu n'as pas tuer ça une proxénète
à éliminer le noyau dur de la mafia
russe de la côte est avec un tel savoir
faire je veux savoir qu'il est
réellement il n'arrêtera pas tant qu'il
n'aura pas tuer toi et toutes les
personnes auxquelles tu tires bon
j'ai remonté jusqu'au sommet ouais
à
ça suffit comme ça
parce que je peux continuer
pierre après pierre cadavres après
cadavres quand vous me regardez
est ce que vous voyez qu'est ce que vous
voyez quand je me regarde et
stone
non